previously on hunter x hunter gohan and
kalua entered the heavens arena to train
and earn some money they met sushi and
his teacher wing who thought them the
basics about nen after reaching the
200th floor gone got defeated by guido
and ended up with broken hand
the story continues after a month with
the people getting excited about the
upcoming match
killuel walks into gone's room shocked
to find him working out on his once
broken arm and astounded gone is
completely healed
the real reason killua came to visit was
to give him tickets to an upcoming
hisoka's fight
killua after getting some information
has found out hisoka's record is eight
to three six knockouts all death
knockouts the only losses he has are
from fights he never showed up to this
means technically hisoka has never lost
in the arena
gon begin shaking with anticipation of
their next fight together killua hopes
gon can learn some kind of strategy to
fight hisoka during the match but gon
worries about the promise he made to
wing about not training in men for two
months
kiluah says it'll be fine until right in
front of them unnoticed by the two is
wing with zushi
he strictly prohibits gone from watching
the match unit of goan is healed the man
that still stands so he must wait
another month he tells go into practice
10 in the meantime
kiluad decides to go alone and see the
match for himself later that day gone is
watching tv when an announcement for
hisoka's match comes up he turns off the
tv it was two years ago castro lost his
match to hisoka and is looking for
revenge
kako the announcer mentions castro's
nine to one record one away from the
four masters kilua decides to sneak into
castro's room to get a better feel for
him suddenly castro asks what he's doing
from behind
killua is petrified looking back in the
room to find the couch empty killua asks
how he was able to sneak up on him but
castro keeps it a secret for one day
they might fight each other
finally hisoka and casters stand in the
ring together as soon as the referee
says start castra charges taking a swing
at hisoka's head though he dodges hisoka
still feels a sharp clean punch to the
face with a surprise look on it
castro attacks again making it easy for
hisoka to see his left hand charging up
hisoka dodges but just like before a
strong swipe comes across the left side
of his face
now the whole audience was quiet
castro is on the attack once again with
ahsoka pulling back he blocks a kick
only for castro to appear behind him and
hit him anyway this time in knockdown
the score now 4-0 the referee asks
hisoka if he can continue he merely
smiles again the same as before and
tries to understand how castro keeps
disappearing
castro begins to charge his special
attack tiger by fist causing the crowd
to go wild
hizoka mockingly gives up his left arm
castro takes his right the crowd screams
as his arm flew through the air hisoka
claims as part of a plan dodging another
attack from castro and catching his arm
hisoka has determined castro's nen
ability is making it double and he
confirms it in front of everyone castro
makes a perfect double next to himself
wayne explains that this doppelganger is
a person who takes energy from the
original and though castro may look fine
he's using an enormous amount of men
every time he creates one
castro charges his ultimate special
ability true tiger bite fist hasoka
calmly spins his own severed arm on his
finger and smiles at castro revealing a
handkerchief and using it to cover the
severed arm
he prepares to show off his powers of
clairvoyance and tosses the covered arm
into the air but several playing cards
are the only things under the
handkerchief with the severed arm
nowhere to be found
as the cards fall to the floor hisoka
asks castro to pick one of the numbers
add four multiply it by two subtract 6
divided by 2 and then subtract the
original number with the crowd left
confused hisoka confidently claims that
he already knows castro's answer
suddenly reaching into the womb on his
right arm and drawing the ace of spades
the announcer and audience are left in
disbelief by the act with killuel
wondering how hisoka can be so calm
hisoka tosses the card toward castro who
quickly knocks it away from himself as
the other remains in its stance after
castro vows to sever hisoka's left arm
as well hisoka voluntarily holds it out
and offers to let him take it one of the
castros charges forward and immediately
severs the arm but the double quickly
disappears afterwards hizoka tells
castro that he expected him to attack
with his double and adds that he would
have countered if he himself had
attacked suddenly revealing that his
right arm has been completely reattached
with everyone left stunned hisoka
explains that it's another magic trick
and asks castro if he can discover the
secret hisoka walks toward castro and
asks if he's afraid
pointing out that he doesn't understand
the trick because it's magic he
continues to walk forward and reveals
that he only spared castro's life before
because of his potential lethally
predicting that he will now die in a
frenzy dance castro angrily tells him to
be quiet and leaves toward him with his
double but hizoka instantly looks for
the real castro causing him to freeze
with fear and wonder how he knew
as hisoka easily dodges the doubles
attacks he explains to castro that he
can't recreate every effect of a battle
on his double
after castro looks down and sees the
blood on his clothes he charges toward
hisoka whose severed left arm suddenly
flies for castro and strikes him in the
face with castor left dazed by the punch
to his chin kisoka explains that he
won't be able to dodge his next attack
and several playing cards suddenly fly
toward castro although castro tries to
create a double the playing cards pierce
castro's body it's announced that hisoka
has won by knockout leaving the arena
hisoka finds a woman waiting for him in
the exit tunnel she praises his victory
and tells him to show her the injury
with the two making their way to
hisoka's room
holding hisoka's severed arms a woman
tells him that the match confirmed that
he's an idiot wondering why he would put
himself in so much danger and asking if
it was a performance hisoka gives a
vague response and the woman points out
that she can't complain since she's
getting paid using threads made of nen
to first stop the bleeding hisoka asks
her to be gentle and the woman tells him
to put away his aura starting with his
left arm and using her neck stitches to
reattach it
hisoka praises her skill as she fixes
his right arm next playfully saying that
he should get injured more so that he
can watch her work the woman ignores the
comment and asks for a payment hisoka
then attached the handkerchief to his
right arm and then creates a layer of
skin over it as hisoka does the same on
his left arm the one explains that
hizoka's bungee gum allows him to mold
his aura into a substance similar to
rubber and gum
allowing it to stretch contract and
stick to many types of surfaces she then
remembers the reason why she came and
tells him that all phantom troop members
have to be in york new city by noon on
august 30th
hisoka asks if the boss will be there as
well and the woman replies that it's
very likely since it could be their
biggest job yet warning him that the
boss may hunt him down personally if he
skips it gone is shown still sitting
alone in his room and meditating when
killua returns he asked about hisoka's
match hiluwa answers that the fight was
incredible and that he has no idea how
hisoka won helen gone that they need to
learn more about men
as hisoka takes a shower in his room a
large spider tattoo the four inside its
abdomen is seen across his back however
when hisoka finishes and begins to dry
himself he says that he forgot to remove
it suddenly taking off the tattoo
he thinks about gohan and killua as his
new toys and says that it's time to hunt
the spiders slamming the handkerchief
against the mirror as the tattoo
vanishes
it's revealed that hisoka has been
masquerading as a member of the phantom
troop and considers the group get
another target two months have passed
since gone's match with guido and gon
has kept his promise to not train with
nen in that time wing tells him in kilua
that they will start training with zushi
wayne tells the three to practice ren
and learns gyo a technique that focuses
the aura in one's eyes allowing one to
see hidden nen
zushi is able to execute gyo in front of
everybody but quickly gets tired
wing tells both gon and kilua to learn
guil for fighting again
the three practices in gon's room when
they leave they run into sadaso guido
and riovult who try forcing them to
fight against them after zushi parts
ways from gon and kilua sadaso ambush
him with his aura arm and takes one of
zushi's shoes
luckily hiluwa followed zushi and got
there just in time to stop sadaso he
agrees to fight and promises he'll let
the three of them win
he adds that they better leave gon alone
and not to go against their word
meanwhile guido calls gon and tells him
to open the door
it reveals zushi's stolen shoe which
implies that they're going to harm zushi
gohan being worried about zushi's
situation agrees to gido's conditions
the next day gon and kalua learn to use
gyo kiluad is also able to work out
hisoka's abilities by using geo which
amazes everybody wing permits gon and
killua to fight
killua is walking outside when he hears
a man selling tickets to gon and guido's
newest match
killua becomes furious that sadaso's
group broke their deal so soon after
making it and infiltrates sebasto's room
and threatens him
killula scares and warns sada so that
the next time he shows his face you will
kill him the next day their match comes
and kalua easily wins when sadaso
doesn't show up sabaso contacts guido
and realville to warn them not to mess
with gon and killua because they're very
dangerous
however riovolt plans to continue his
tricks in order for him to achieve his
goal of becoming a floor master
suddenly kalua appears out of nowhere
and warns both realvelt and ghido to
play nice gone wins his first 200th
floor match beating sadasso by default
before their matches against realvelt
and guido gone and kilua train even more
gomenkito's rematch begins but this time
gone carries his father's fishing rod
gone starts off by running towards his
opponent but gido uses his tornado top
to halt gone's attack followed by
shotgun blues gone is able to repel
guido's attack using wren and prepares
his pole ghido realizes that gon plans
to stop him from spinning gone releases
his fishing rod and aims toward his
opponent
for a moment gideon laughs that gone
missed but gohan has attached the
fishing rod hook to one of the
flagstones of the ring and froze it
upwards causing guido to fly
jitto is helpless as gohan breaks his
prosthetic leg gone gains his second
victory
after the match kiluah faces against
realvelt killuva jumps high but before
he hits his opponent railvelt uses
auraburs to escape kiluah merely shrugs
it off blaming that he jumped too high
riovelt then takes out his weapon the
twinning snake
he attacks kilauea with it but killua is
able to catch both whips rioville
presses buttons sending a large amount
of electricity at kiluah he calls this
move the thundersnake however due to his
training when he was a kid kiluah is
able to withstand the electricity
although he still feels a slight amount
of pain
kiluah throws railvelt above the ground
and he begs kilua to save him
kiluad agrees and catches him while
holding his thunder snake causing
riovelt to be completely electrified
kiluah earns his second win after a few
days the fight between killua and guido
is supposed to take place but ghido is
unable to compete because of the damage
he took from gon gone faces reveal next
and quickly revel takes out his weapons
but gone lifts up another flagstone and
throws it towards him he dodges by using
aura burst but gohan anticipates this
move and stops him takes his twin snake
wraps it around railvelt's neck and
scares him that he will turn on the
switch
realvolt falls unconscious and gone
becomes the winner after the fight go
meets up with hisoka and he praises gon
for the progression he made and agrees
to fight him next
after hisoka agrees to fight him gon
continues to train very hard in nan
along with killua and zushi
wing teaches them about hatsu and
explains the six types of aura
enhancement transmutation conjuration
emission manipulation and specialization
as well as the importance of knowing the
type 1 is born into and the
compatibility they have with each other
he uses castro kisoka and guido as
examples hisoka is able to turn his aura
into a rubber-like substance which
indicates that he's a transmuter
guido uses his aura to increase the
spinning and concussive force of the
tops he uses to a great effect which is
an enhancer ability however to
manipulate so many objects require the
skill of a manipulator which is
incompatible with the enhancement
category thus negating the effectiveness
of his attack caster's tiger bite fist
was very effective and was most likely
in the enhancement category as well
however he made the decision to create
doppelganger which is a conjurer ability
and required the skill a manipulator to
control it
mather category is compatible with
enhancement as a result castro
squandered his talent and then ability
next he introduces the water divination
a specific and one of the easiest ways
to know which type of aura a man user
has wayne demonstrates how to do it and
they find out which category they fall
into
go makes the water overflow which means
he belongs in the enhancement category
kiluah makes the water taste sweet
putting him in the transmutation
category zushi makes the leaf move on
top of the water meaning he is in
manipulation the three continue to train
hard after a few weeks when gon believes
he's ready he sets a schedule for his
fight with hisoka wig announces that
gohan has passed the secret hunter exam
gon asks if any of his friends passed
and wing tells him that karapika and
hanzo have already passed while pokel is
still struggling with ren and liorio as
studying for his medical exam
wayne also explains that learning men is
part of being a hunter in order to be
strong and fight criminals
he also comments that netero is the head
of his school of men
he then encourages kilua to take the
hunter exam next year because kimwa is
more than qualified to become a hunter
on july 10th gong's match with hisoka
takes place the stadium is crowded with
supporters and the two fighters are
ready in the arena gone runs towards
kasoka and tries to attack him but
hizoka is able to dodge and block every
single one of his attacks without moving
from his place when hisoka boasts that
he himself hasn't moved since the
beginning of the match gom becomes more
determined he shows his power and
agility by grabbing and yanking a
flagstone and throwing in front of
hisoka gom shatters the stone startling
hisoka but he punches the rubble away
gone disappears from hisoka's sight and
is able to sneak from behind allowing
him to finally deliver a solid punch
straight to hisoka's face
after going hits hisoka in the face the
referee gives him a critical hit which
brings the match score to two to one
afterward gon gives back hisoka's number
plate everyone is confused at the
exchange hisoka gets going using his
elbow and continues attacking gone while
gon defends gon uses gyo and sees
hisoka's bungee gum attached to gon's
cheek
hisoka uses his bungee gum to pull gone
towards him and delivers a punch that
knocks gone down
the referee gives hisoka a critical hit
and a knock down making the score six to
two as the battle continues gon runs
towards hisoka and lands a punch to his
face
hizoka then becomes absorbed in thought
and excitement allowing gon to keep
punching his face
during his period hisoka enters an
orgasmic-like state at the thought of
gon becoming stronger and realizing his
potential not before long he snaps out
of it and counters gone's assault the
punch to gon hisoka pulls gone by the
bungee gum and punches him again but
gone blocks his attack but still is
stunned a bit
the referee gives critical points to
both fighters but gives hisoka an extra
knockdown point which gon complains that
he was never down
the referee stands by his decision and
the crowd also questions the referee as
they begin to boo the score changes to
nine to four in favor of hisoka hisoka
tricks go by making him look to his
right and a large stone hits gon
resulting in knock down points which
gave hisoka the victory
hisoka while leaving the arena tells
gone that he has made a lot of progress
but still lacks experience if he can win
10 more fights he can stand a chance in
heaven's arena however hisoka tells gone
that he has no intention of fighting him
again in heaven's arena instead he wants
to fight him in the real world where
their lives are at stake gohan wants to
train hard in order to fight and beat
hisoka gon and killua bid farewell to
wing and zushi the two decide to visit
gone's aunt mito on whale island so they
finally bid farewell to heaven's arena
the end of part five be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
to not miss the next parts